hi everyone mad luigi here and today i'm
going to be doing something a little bit
different instead of my normal scripted
deep dive lore video i'm going to be
reviewing and ranking in a tier list the
bosses of eldon ring not all of the
bosses as i don't want this to be a
two-hour video i'm just going to be
reviewing and ranking the 15 main bosses
of the game the ones that have
remembrances
even though i have been making lots of
elden ring videos i haven't actually
been playing the game that much so i
wanted to get back into it a little bit
and i did that with a new game plus run
of killing all of the main bosses these
remembrances so while i'm working on
other videos like lore and critiques and
philosophy of eldon ring i thought it
would be a fun idea to just do this
ranking tier list in the meantime so i
hope you all enjoy watching the video if
you do make sure to subscribe to the
channel as it really helps out and you
can even support me on patreon if you
really like my content with that said
let's get into the bosses of eldon ring
and my ranking of them
first up is margat and as you know we
don't get a remembrance from fighting
margaret the first time but he is still
a pretty interesting boss fight he is
the basic introduction to the game in
terms of boss fights because most people
play him as the first boss and i'm not
counting the soldier of godric as a
meaningful first boss and so i thought
it would be meaningful to rank him and
then revisit him once i come back to
look at morgan so looking at market i
think it's a great thematic fight it's
moody it's interesting and he's an
interesting enemy that leaves the first
time player wondering more when he dies
both for his interesting design and for
his dying curse about the hands of the
fel omen i think the mechanics are
overall solid and they make for a good
fight and the different weapons via
magic tail and staff add variety but
there are definitely some gamey
interplay with the unrealistically long
delay in some of his swings and in the
continuous strings of follow-up attacks
if margate can immediately small dagger
sideswipe after a long combo the player
can feel like they don't get a proper
punishment opportunity after they've
dodged a bunch
while an optimal player can keep
pressure up while running away with
extra tools like throwing daggers most
players especially the first time
they're playing and the first main boss
they're fighting aren't going to be
engaging at a fully optimal level and so
they'll be on the other end of the
spectrum with long periods of delay
between engagements with the boss a lack
of posture bar also shrouds the mechanic
to the point that many players won't
realize it's worth it to keep pressure
up in any way they can like occasionally
throwing daggers the daggers don't
really do very much damage so a player
might not see any purpose to it even
though one or two every once in a while
in between attacks can make it so you
can posture break margat in a reasonable
amount of time so it's a solid fight but
it does highlight some of the issues
that will come to be a problem in a lot
of bosses and a lot of the gameplay of
eldon ring if it was free of kind of the
gaminess and excessive amount of delays
and speedy attacks i would be okay with
some of them for roll catching i would
put this as s-tier but because it has
those issues i'm gonna put the market
fight as an a-tier maybe sdr fight
next up is the first fully fledged
demigod we meet godric the grafted
godric has an interesting design and
silhouette he has pretty good lore and a
fitting phase 2 that adds to the phase 1
with new power ups though he does have a
few annoying attacks design wise there
are long combos and immediately
summoning wind that is only avoidable by
staying away the first time i went
through the game i didn't have much
issue with the wind summoning attack and
even playing through again on new game
plus i didn't have much issue with it
but the speed with which it comes out is
basically impossible to dodge if you're
staying close to him so you have to stay
away which is okay but then even when
i'm attacking godric in neutral if he
immediately summons the wind when i'm
going in for attack i'm punished when it
looked like there was an opening or at
least it looked like to me there's
nearly no telegraph for it so you can
get randomly punished when you're going
in for an attack or if you're staying
close to him somewhat unfairly it's not
the largest issue and i think it's an
overall decent fight
but it is something that's present so i
will put godric in the b tier he isn't
as interesting to me as margaret but
he's a solid fight i enjoy him good
gameplay solid stuff
next up is ronaldo who i think has great
design and an intriguing phase one to
phase two the first time you play it at
least but subsequent runs phase one is
really just a chore especially when
ronaldo has one of the longest boss run
backs in the game they really add to
each other and make it pretty annoying
to go through she has a good kit of
attacks the mix of spells including new
moon spells that we've seen for the
first time during her fight and
summoning creates a good pressure for
the player it's kind of an easy fight
and i do hear that as criticism even
though the first time i played the game
i think it took me a decent number of
tries but i always feel decently
pressured when i'm in the fight even
going through new game plus i feel like
she's a good kind of difficulty where
none of the moves seem designed to catch
a player or manufactured to oh i got you
when you're rolling because i knew you
were going to be doing that timing
because we're used to that in previous
games i think there's just solid
pressure and with ronald's movements
backwards to create space it feels very
natural and very fitting for a mage like
enemy to do that it's a really just nice
mix of all of the different abilities i
feel like this is one of the best
examples of a boss feeling very natural
unlike what we saw with margat and
somewhat with godric because of the
benefits i'm going to choose to put
ranala in the a tier the boss run back
and the phase 1 are pretty detrimental
and so maybe i should be giving those
more credit and putting her in b tier
but i think it's just i had a really
good time with the fight the last time i
went through it and i thought it was a a
good experience so i'm going to go with
a tier now we might start getting
controversial with my opinion on radon
i'm pretty sure radon was the winner of
favorite boss when i did the circuit
polling in my community so my criticisms
of him might sound a bit much i do think
the fight thematically and everything
building up to it the festival i think
it all creates a grand spectacle
especially with his lore and fighting
him in a giant sand dune arena that's
its whole own world basically
now i really think that part of that
spectacle is fighting radon with all of
the summons with it being a war festival
and the dialogue we get afterwards it
really reads to me that the game is
pushing and promoting fighting radon
with all of the summons it's the only
fight in the game and i think any
fromsoft game that i've played where we
have that aspect of tons and tons of
summons in the boss arena and able to be
re-summoned when they die
however when we fight radon in this way
it really turns into a gimmick fight
fighting him with so many people and
attacking so once in a while and his ai
jumping between multiple people kind of
turns it into a gimmick fight where
you're not engaging in the same way as
you would in a normal 1v1 boss fight or
in most of the boss fights of fromsoft's
design
it's really because there's no special
ai for radon to account for the multiple
targets and enemies i think this is a
broader issue with the game and the
emphasis on summons but it really leads
to issue if you're trying to treat the
fight as methodical especially because
this can lead to erratic hits if you are
too close to radon on foot when there
are other npcs around it's hard to
predict what attack he's going to do or
where it's going to go when it's
swapping between different targets
now when you're using the summoning it
really pushes you to use the horse to
kind of avoid this but that limits your
engagement with radon because you're
hitting him less frequently you're going
in less often and it leads to the player
often sitting back you can 1v1 him you
can always choose to do that but the
giant figure of radon plus bad camera
angles and awkwardness of occasionally
needing torrent but generally having to
stay on foot to dodge attacks all gets
in the way of what is sometimes a really
fun one-on-one this could be helped if
torrent had more combat capabilities or
some iframes on dashes or just something
to give torrent more tools to deal with
radon and this could help the fight
whether it's 1v1 or with summons having
torrent be able to do more could make it
more interactive because when radon is
on his horse all the time you want to
match him on the horse overall for the
fight either as a gimmick or an unclean
one-on-one i think it could have been
better with more fleshed out torn
options and maybe trying to choose more
between one option or the other gimmick
or 1v1 i appreciate the ability to
choose and i do find beneficial aspects
in both but the issues do get in the way
for me to really experience this as a
fun and enjoyable fight because of the
issues i'm going to put radon at b tier
even though i would probably say he's
better than godric part of the reason
i'm doing this here list is because i
don't want to say specifically this boss
is better than this boss is better than
this boss i don't want to make a one to
one list because there would be too many
considerations to do as casually as
right now i'm sure if i really really
sat down maybe i could but i would say
radon is better than godric but i enjoy
the market and the ranala fights more
than i do redon almost any time i fight
him
next up is going to be the last
candidate for great rune before you get
into langdale and that is riker riker
probably has one of if not the best
environment setting and thematics for
his boss fight volcano manor is a great
intro area to prepare you for the fight
but you're still surprised by what you
find you see the snakes you see the lava
you get prepared in theme for it but
when you find this giant god devouring
serpent it's a really interesting and
just and thrilling experience i really
enjoyed it riker's voice actor is
obviously fantastic but when i was first
going through the game i think riker was
my favorite boss up to that point and he
held on pretty well throughout the rest
of the game now it is a gimmick fight
obviously and it can be a bit reductive
mechanically due to spamming weapon art
being probably the best thing you can do
but my first playthrough i felt like i
had a natural use of the kit of all the
different attacks that the serpent
hunter i think is the name of the weapon
can use even if i now recognize that i
was playing sub optimally by not
spamming l2 repeatedly for the entire
fight i think riker has a good kit of
diverse cool attacks though the ground
lava was something i was never able to
learn how to dodge i would try out
running i would try dodging at the right
time maybe it's just a flaw of me still
having the timings wrong despite playing
through him a couple times but it's now
still an issue i haven't gotten over
even though i've been able to deal with
the rest of his kit maybe some more
variation in the snake attacks would
make for a better experience for phase
one like you could have things falling
from the ceiling because there's all the
destruction that's going on with the
pillars or there could be a rumbling
earthquake you can jump over maybe the
ground lava kind of acts like that i
think it would be interesting to have an
aoe going out from record that's
basically like a jump over earthquake
and let me know if there is some attack
like that that i'm forgetting or didn't
run into in new game plus and just
completely forgot it so i think there
are some faults with this fight after
all it is a gimmick fight that really
pushes you to use the boss weapon but i
think it's a fantastically done gimmick
boss and one of the coolest action set
pieces that we get in the game and it
still somewhat stays true to the souls
like gameplay since you are still
interacting in a similar methodical way
of dodging and waiting for an opening to
attack even though it's a modified
gimmick version i think something like
this is what they wanted to do but
failed with yorm and i think it's just
really successful so riker is going to
be my first estier of the tier list
which is unsurprising because i said he
was my favorite in the game when i first
started
next up we have another
maybe controversial opinion the regal
ancestral spirit i love this boss it has
amazing scenery and atmosphere it has
outstanding music the soundtrack is my
favorite out of probably any song in the
game i think it's the best in the game
everything in here feels otherworldly
which is very fitting for the setting of
the boss a kind of old natural being
that was forgotten by the order and the
world and exists pretty secluded from
all of them it's underground and even
then it's separated from the knox and
the eternal cities it's its own thing
and the boss setting and arena really
match that vibe it could use a bit more
of a power up in phase 2 and it does
suffer from being a bit too easy my
first time playing through the game i
was sad that the spirit died so quickly
because i wanted to have the fight
extend and go on longer so it could do
with a kit with a few more options for
pressure maybe like making the smaller
creature spirits in the arena attack you
or by using spirit projectiles other
than fire some sort of utilization of
old power would be pretty cool overall
this is one of if not my favorite fight
in the game so it is unquestionably for
me an esteer boss it is my probably my
favorite boss still the music is
probably going a really long way in that
because i just absolutely love the
soundtrack but i do just really really
really really enjoy the ancestor spirit
fight and if more of the fights in elder
ring were more like it i don't know
specifically in which way but if they
just captured the same kind of energy
that i get from this fight i think i
would have been happier with the bosses
in the game
and before we get to lane del we have
one more underground boss and that's
estelle estelle is thematically very
strong a stolen night sky in an
underground cave plus being at the end
of ronnie's quest line it would have
more of an impact if we never saw any of
the grey mini estelles and we just the
first time we saw this estelle we were
left completely surprised by the form
and the design and the otherworldly
alien planetness i think that would have
hit home a little bit more it's not too
big of an issue because even my first
playthrough i saw those grey estelles
because they were so monotone and always
kind of on the side or on the edge
you're running away from them they're
hanging from the ceiling they're not
like the main focus like you're fighting
them so it's not the biggest issue but
it is something that could have helped
with the impact estelle's attacks have
an okay variety but it did feel like he
often spammed down slam against me there
are lots of aoe attacks that make for
lots of running away run back in repeat
so i thought the mechanics were not
horribly engaging but the setting is
very cool and it's a decent fight so
while the setting is impressive the
fight itself just doesn't get that much
out of me it's not a bad fight but it's
not that good of one either in my
opinion so for these reasons i'm going
to put estelle at b tier a cell doesn't
reach the same heights or the same
glaring issues as radon um so maybe it's
more like godric in that it's pretty
good it's nothing super super great or
bad either way the setting for estelle
is really fantastic but i'm basically
just repeating myself at this point the
fight itself didn't have enough to pull
me to bring it up to margaret or ronaldo
and speaking of margaret now that we
beat estelle we are going to lane del
where we fight against the proper form
of market which is morgot and i don't
actually know if i like morgot better
than market in terms of a fight morgut
is an upgraded market with a more proper
phase 2 more variety more weapons and it
seems like more annoying delays and long
chains of attack morgot is a solid fight
and one of the most vanilla in the game
when it comes to presentation and
thematics it's an arena it's pretty
simple colors it's just the city of
landell it is golden it is at the foot
of the archery but it is pretty
straightforward in just a 1v1 in a
square arena with some chairs it's
simple but it works for a nice
semi-humanoid 1v1 if not for the small
issues of the kind of over-engineering
and unrealistic delays i think the flow
and the dance of morgot would be more
easily achievable and i think that would
make him an estier fight as it is now
maybe some can get into that flow state
easily but i only get glimpses of it
when i fight him so i'm going to say
that he remains in the a tier he's a
good fight but there are issues that
prevent me from really really just
sinking my teeth into it and having fun
and one of the issues that has come up
here in market and will come up later
that i have with the kind of delays is
they do serve a mechanical purpose in
that they can change up timing and make
it so the player has to think about the
rolling not panic roll it can roll catch
but there is an issue to it that takes
me out of my immersion out of the
feeling like i'm in the game and it's
when a character is charging up an
attack and doing an overhead swing and
just sitting there with it they're
basically leaving themselves open to
attack at least they are if i'm actually
in game but because this is a game
it's not a large opening it's just a way
to delay to catch the player when
they're rolling with margat morgan and i
think ratagon is a really good example
you can attack them when they're
charging up these attacks but you never
really delay them you never posture
break them during these attacks and that
leads to a feeling of it's not really an
opening even when it looks like it is
one and yeah looks can be deceiving what
not yes but for me it feels like it kind
of takes me out of the game by
highlighting the fact that it is a game
like it feels very gamey and that kind
of hurts my immersion so that's just a
kind of description of the issue i'm
having with the bosses when i'm talking
about that kind of delay and one of the
reasons why it negatively impacts my
gameplay of it next up we have a boss
below lane dell and that is litch dragon
fortis axe i don't know if it's lich
dragon or lick dragon i never played dnd
or anything that actually had a lick or
lich that whatever that weird skeleton
overlord is i don't know how to
pronounce it this boss has killer
visuals paired with a killer soundtrack
where an organ goes so hard it sounds a
bit like electric rock music to me the
dual lightning effects really make for
an intimidating and electric feel
especially with the vibe of the music
that i just mentioned i think the attack
kit has alright diversity if a bit
repetitive with dragon attacks of
lightning slams and the constant
tracking shock does add pressure but in
a bit of an annoying way the death
flight never presented too much concern
to me so maybe adding another deathblade
attack or changing up the area it's in
so it's a little bit more pressure on
the player maybe it's tighter aoe but
it's more close to the dragon that would
maybe make for a better fight there were
significant camera issues which made me
unable to appreciate what i'm sure were
stunning aerial movements and attacks i
would have liked to see fortis x going
up to the air and coming down and all
their dragon glory but i just couldn't
see it because the camera wouldn't let
me look up the tracking was an issue
this is an issue fromsoft has with a lot
of the big bosses in eldon ring and it's
really apparent in this fight because of
this dodging the attacks also became
somewhat of a guessing game it was never
too difficult to do but it was just an
issue and i also heard concerns of low
health which i kind of remember from my
first playthrough but i haven't fought a
new game in a while going back recently
i fought him on new game plus and he had
pretty okay health the boss fight has a
lot going for it and the presentation is
great but the issues do add up so i'm
going to put border sax in b or a tier
and thinking about it hmm i think the
presentation and just the coolness
factor with the fight being pretty
decent i think that'll put it into a
tier for me i don't have as much issues
as i have with radon and i think it is
distinctly better than estelle and
godric i had a better time with it
next up is a boss i did not have a
better time with and that is the fire
giant which is an intriguing enemy by
design it's the last of the fire giants
and it's a mighty torrent fight i like
utilizing torrent in a fight and it
feels like this is a fitting fight to do
so but torrent doesn't have many
mechanics so it's not that great of an
addition and the mechanics for the fight
i feel like are pretty met the camera is
on his feet the whole time and most
attacks aren't visible from where you
can attack the giant you can't see most
of his attacks when you're attacking him
because you're so close and the camera
is so close uh you can see his foot
stomps but that's about it didn't make
too much of an issue in terms of
difficulty for me never felt like a
horribly difficult fight but overall the
fight is pretty lackluster it's not
terrible it's not that this is an
absolutely terrible fight i think it's
somewhat well made in the sense that
most of the stuff in the game despite
included are made to a certain level of
professionality and that makes sense
since farmsoft has kind of been honing
this design of game for many years
nothing is absolutely terrible or mind
boggling or takes me completely out and
it's like this is an atrocious game but
when i'm raiding the fights this is one
of the worst ones it's one of the most
math fights in the game mechanically to
me and because of that i have to rank it
pretty lowly i think it will be my first
d tier because it's it's really bad it's
not fun i might make it sea tier when we
get to the elden beast it might be
unquestionable that that is much farther
below so for now actually i'll bring him
up the seat here the fire giant he's not
atrocious he's not terrible he's just
very unengaging to me not very fun i
don't look forward to him so next up
after the fire giant we get to go to
pharam azula and fight malakin malketh
has a nice progression from grank in
phase 1 to malikith in phase 2. but
there are lots of annoying attacks and
market-esque timings there are a few
delays and the phase 1 dagger slash is
too quick in my opinion you have to
avoid being too close to him or get
lucky and not get hit by it often times
there feels like there's no opening to
punish in phase 2 and maybe i should
qualify that i recently played with a
great sword so the punish windows do
have to be longer for me but generally
doing a roll attack or a jump attack in
the openings there are still leaves me
open to get damage and i have to
basically trade damage or that's what it
feels like when i'm fighting i know
there are people of course in every one
of these games that can fight every boss
no hit so there are openings but from my
level of play which i think is pretty
decent i'm not a terrible player these
issues really pop up as i said there
might be openings on completely optimal
play but for my first playthrough and
what seems to be common sentiment and
when i was even playing on this recent
new game plus is that there aren't many
openings if you aren't playing at that
optimal level it ends up with phase 2
having quite long holes where you
basically just dodged for a long time
waiting to get one hit in i think
there's not enough use of the
blasphemous claw or a game that does
emphasize a little bit more of the rpg
elements over the action at least
relative to my feeling on previous from
games you don't get a lot of use out of
the blasphemous claw because there
really aren't many attacks that malakith
uses where you can use the claw i've
done many runs where i feel like i
haven't seen a single golden attack that
i can use the blasphemous claw on or i'm
just missing attacks that do have an
opening for the claw's use and i think
this point is especially strong because
a successful parry with the claw doesn't
even give a visceral attack or a post
option it just kind of turns malakath
into kind of a woozy state who can be
hit by a few more attacks but he can
also attack a little bit during it so if
it's not even gonna give us a repost
option there should be more
opportunities to use the claw a dance
with malakith could be a nice flow but
it feels like there are too many juts
getting in the way of that flow for
these reasons i'm going to put malaketh
in seat here he is more engaging than
the fire giant but he has more
significant issues to him as well
after malakath we come back to lane del
covered in ash and we fight horolu
warrior he has a compelling presentation
for a very built up figure godfrey the
first elven lord and his phase two is a
nice flip on the standard golden order
roll it's not something to super expect
and it's an interesting change in the
presentation and the fighting style
phase one is solid and phase two does
introduce some of the annoying delays or
super speedy grabs or zooms kind of one
or the other just really trying to catch
the player's typical timing to say ha
gotcha and to some degree what i said
before it's annoying because it's
playing against the timings that a
player would expect not just from
previously playing the games but also
from the visual cues of the movements of
horoloop the animations feel like he's
going to become at a certain timing and
then he comes at a different whether
faster or slower and you could say this
adds variety or it adds difficulty but
it just feels like not the kind of
difficulty that feels really good to me
you do have to learn the timings which
is a staple of like from soft fights
it's always a timing game but it's done
in a way that for lack of a better
phrase rubs me the wrong way it just
doesn't feel great with the animations
that i'm seeing and i can get more into
detail in a more dedicated critique
which i'm sure i'll do sometime in the
future maybe not horolu specifically but
the bosses in general and i will look at
a few specifics but phase 2 is still
pretty fun you would expect a lot of
pressure from the warrior constantly
pressing you but the mechanical
execution of it is just a little
lackluster it's kind of meh also to have
aoe attacks that cover nearly the whole
arena if i'm so far away that i can
barely see horloo i would think the
attacks should dissipate a bit but it
feels like i can be 90 across the arena
and it's so good in me not as a very
technical uh description i don't know
how much it actually covers of the arena
that's the feeling i got one playing and
if i was very far away i still had to
dodge just the same as if i was very
close up and i can adjust my play style
for that but it just like feels kind of
odd with what i'm seeing in the game it
feels gamey and kind of taking me out of
it so with all that said i'm going to
put horolu in
i would put him in either the b or the a
tier i do think he's pretty good he does
have some issues do i think he's better
than estelle for don and godric do i
think he's as good as ranala the dragon
and morgot
i don't know i would put him in b a if i
could but i don't have that here so i
know my first time playing through the
game i really didn't like him but i was
also trying to beat the game pretty
quickly and he was frustrating because i
wanted to make videos about the game so
we're going to put him
in
i'll put him in beat here for now i
didn't really enjoy him at all until
recently all right for now and maybe if
i'm feeling feeling gracious later we'll
move them up today we'll see
so gameplay-wise this could be after
horolu and it could be after the eldon
beast as well but i'm pretty sure i
fought him actually earlier so now we're
going to be looking at dragon lord
placidusa dragon lord placidou6 has a
great arena for a thematic fight there's
a good range of attacks i think phase
two would probably be cooler with more
flying and less teleporting the
teleporting is interesting but seeing
plasti-du6 fly around the stage would be
even cooler add in more of the shrouded
cloud red lightning in the clouds
effects and i think it would just be
even greater it's already really good
right now it's a great effect very
interesting i really enjoy the fight and
there could also be some other aspect
that would capitalize on the grandiosity
of it maybe something a la divine dragon
from sekito that fight was more of a
gimmick but adding something in a little
bit like that one into this fight could
not make it a gimmick just elevate the
greatness of the feeling of the fight
because it's such a grandiose fight
already it is a really enjoyable fight
there aren't any significant issues i
have with it it's a solid fight it's
dramatic just a little bit more thematic
pumping in the gameplay and i think it
could have been nest here but because it
doesn't super grab my fancy um i'll put
it in a tier it's a really solid fight
it's just enjoyable and maybe maybe i
would give it ester if it didn't have a
terrible boss run back yes makes sense
that there's no statue of america i
guess because it's out of time and space
but it's just i hate boss run backs i
made a video previously about how boss
run backs are a terrible aspect of the
game they are maybe a necessary aspect
for invading but now invading doesn't
even happen to solo players unless you
use taunting tongue so i guess that
argument wasn't very strong i really
hate boston backs and it's annoying it's
surprising i give two of the bosses with
the worst boss run backs are a tier for
me ronaldo probably wouldn't be asked
here without the from back she would
need more to get to str um plastic d6
could maybe make an argument i really
don't like the boss run back though
especially the first time i was playing
the game so that'll be where that is and
next up i'm going to do moog because
he's pretty late game for me i fought
him after i beat the game um generally
but he uh not as oomphy to me so we're
gonna we're gonna review him next moog
has a really good build up mogun palace
as an arena is really well done i really
like it as a optional extra area i think
if more of the end game was kind of like
that it was a little bit more condensed
and kind of focused it would have been a
better experience if it was just all a
bit shorter and a bit focused i think it
would have been great so i like most
build up arena in terms of thematics in
terms of gameplay it's all a good setup
and his phase one is okay but there are
definitely the annoying delays which to
me break immersion and there's like the
really long wait for an overhead swing
but as a player i can't punish the
opening it feels gamey in a bad way i
can't have a mini poise break at all i
can't interrupt it or maybe i can but
with my great sword i'm just not doing
enough i would say with this build if
this build isn't interrupting it then
most builds aren't going to in terms of
discussing if you meaningfully can do it
i would say no it feels like there's an
opening there should be visually there
is and there isn't an opening in the way
that i would want out of it maybe you
can get a slight attack in during the
delay but it's not enough given how big
of an opening there feels like there is
phase two could be a good upgrade to
phase one a lot of the attacks are newly
imbued with blood flame it's a good
classic way to do a phase two but it
does really become a spam fest with
flame randomly strewn on the ground the
flame seems to end up in the arena with
random damage zones that doesn't give
any rhyme or reason to certain areas
having damage because it's just wherever
moog is shooting them and this is unlike
dedicated area damage that make for
intentional obstacles and i think those
are generally better to spew the boss
arena with kind of like morgot's golden
reigning sword attack i think that's a
better way of adding pressure and
putting obstacles for the player other
than just spewing fire around it just
feels like it gets in the way and it's
not super engaging because it can just
stack up randomly and then oh i have to
just stand in this little corner it's
just not the most well done or engaging
for me maybe that could be a matter of
taste as opposed to design but i would
say design wise i think something a
little bit closer even if it could still
somewhat be random to something like
morgot's reigning sword attack is a a
better experience a better design also
moog flying away a bunch doesn't help
for the fight maybe i liked him more on
my first playthrough and maybe a new
game he's better than new game plus but
with a recent new game plus fight he
just felt more ugh than good flow i
didn't enjoy the fight so i'm going to
be putting mogue in c tier there isn't
anything pulling me there's a good theme
good setting but he's not super engaging
maybe if i try another run with a
different build i'll feel more variety
on it but i've played with different
builds in the game my first playthrough
i had a couple different builds and
those were all different than my current
mainly strength build for a new game
plus so i don't know mo just isn't doing
it for me
next up we're going to look at the final
boss of the game the elden beast at
least the elden beast is what is shown
on the remembrance but as we obviously
know it is a phase one phase two fight
where the phase one is very different
than the phase two the phase one being
ratagon the phase two being the elden
beast i think radagon on his own would
probably get an a tier for me he has an
interesting design and a fun kit to
fight against in a 1v1 it's a pretty
fitting 1v1 final boss fight i think
it's just a solid 1v1 there's a little
bit of delaying attacks and you can
attack him during those but for the most
part it feels like a comfortable dance
could do with less teleporting in his
second mini phase maybe that's the thing
i have with teleporting i would like a
little bit less of it but overall pretty
solid i like the radagon fight it's not
quite as good as soul of cinder the soul
of cinder is in my opinion the one on
one in one of the best ways i think gail
is also that one-on-one in a really
outstanding way from dark souls 3 but
ratagon is solid however the elden beast
is not the infamous elden beast the
elden beast is terrible it takes the
cake for actions which don't let the
player engage or fight so if i have an
issue with ratagan teleporting away i
have 10 times as much of an issue with
the eldon beast being terrible the elden
beast is unquestionably for me the worst
boss in the game in terms of mechanics
or at least the worst remembrance since
there could be a couple small little
tiny bosses that are really terrible it
has okay attacks in general but pair
eldon stars with his infinite runaway
and a lack of torrent in the boss fight
it's basically irredeemable in my eyes
regardless of its interesting setting i
think it does have a decent setting i
think the area it teleports you to is
very cool very alien um everything comes
out of left field in a way that i would
think would be better if there was a
little just a little bit more evidence
or foreshadowing or just a little hint
of something to prepare for it it's just
really random teleportation away to this
new braided will golden tree area like i
think bloodborne did the moon presence
better and obviously the moon presence
is a better fight so with all those
things the elden beast i don't know if i
i could just average them and put them
somewhere in the middle because i like
ratagon and i don't like the elden beast
but because their remembrance is the
elden remembrance and it's basically
just for the beast i'm going to have to
put it
indeed here the building beast is
terrible i hate it irredeemable
um yeah just a bad time i don't like it
like i don't i don't think it's
mechanically well and i think anybody i
think you can like it you can enjoy it
you can enjoy the spectacle um and maybe
you can even be okay with the fight
that's fine but i think from a design
point of view
trying to be
objective it's just not great this is
not good it's just bad it is bad elden
stars and the running away is just i
don't i don't know how there's a defense
of those as design options if anybody in
the comments wants to disagree and
defend ellen stars and running away to
me please feel free to do so from the
point of view of just like good design
because to me it's not engaging it's
unavoidable damage it's just not what i
want from a game especially a friendship
game and especially the the ultimate the
final fight of the game this is this is
the final boss it's it's a complete
letdown it's it's terrible
and lastly we have malene who you all
should know i pronounced melania in i
think my outer gods video and i still
get tons of comments about how i say
melania yes she says her name after she
dies i probably misspelled it i probably
switched the a and e in the script so i
said melania not melania i'm sorry for
the offense i got back at all the people
well enough with my melania lore video
uh if you haven't seen it go check it
out you'll see what i mean pretty
quickly but let's talk about her as a
boss fight since i unfortunately don't
have that much good to say i can say it
has a good phase 1 to phase 2 transition
it is a pretty quintessential use of the
technique of phase 2 being a revamped
version with the elemental damage the
more special effects more longer range
explosions on it kind of similar to gale
maybe just because they have a similar
color in their special attacks but
whereas gale i think is a good fight
melania i don't think is a good fight
phase two is more fun to me than phase
one but i really hardly got to play it
even though i beat melania the boss
fight is very difficult as everybody
will agree but to the part that people
might not agree about i think it's
unfortunately difficult in many bad ways
the hyper armor she has on a lot of
attacks makes it feel like i as a player
don't have as much weight behind my
attacks especially when she's so
staggerable outside of these specific
attacks which get hyper armor having a
bit more balance here where she doesn't
stagger quite as much in general and she
has less hyper armor or even just
leaving more hyper armor for phase two
would have been better in my opinion
phase two we already have a small amount
of openings so it wouldn't be a big deal
for her to have hyper armor during a
good amount of the attacks because we're
already avoiding them so it's just kind
of adds to the severity in which we have
to avoid them saving that for phase two
could have had a little bit more balance
you lower the difficulty of phase one a
little bit but maybe you could even amp
it up a little bit more in phase two
maybe other people had different
experiences but i had a lot more time
spent on phase one than in phase two
there's also lots of rapid recovery and
small punish windows especially after
waterfowl which makes it so that the
player isn't rewarded with engagement as
much after dodging a really long attack
string it's just continuing and
elongating the time that we have to wait
as players and of course there is
waterfowl dance which is an utterly
terrible move that is nearly impossible
to dodge if you don't want to abuse
bloodhound step then you have to either
play extremely passively or get lucky if
you don't want to have your day ruined
by waterfowl it covers so much ground it
functions like a small aoe and can come
out at blazingly fast speeds all of
these things leave the player in a poor
position to deal with it i would much
rather have a flurry of precise attacks
that are more apt for dodging than
something which almost demands
significant running away along with
dodging along with you're probably still
going to get hit unless you do it
perfectly and this is all on top of the
other issues with waterfowl dance being
able to come out so fast it can come out
immediately after you attack her or she
stops another attack so your position
for it can kind of unfairly be punished
and even waterfowl has a very small
punish window after it if you have a
good dodge you can set it up well to
attack her but sometimes my slower
swings were completely not able to
punish and after such a significant
attack arguably the most difficult
attack to dodge or to play around in the
entire game you would expect a
significant window to punish or the
player then attack melania but it just
isn't the case she just keeps on going
with her kit she is basically a sekiro
boss with more polish she could have
been an outstanding fight with a similar
level of difficulty that she has now i
don't think the difficulty is inherently
an issue obviously there's plenty of
difficulty in these games and that's
part of what we want and she's an
optional end game boss a perfect example
for the most difficult thing fromsoft is
going to put in the game and that's okay
it's just that so much of the hardness
right now comes from things and aspects
that don't feel great to fight against
they really just it's not a good
difficulty to me because so many of the
things that make it an issue are just
frustrating i like that she dodges i
don't like that if i clip her during the
dodge there's no posture impact and she
keeps bulldozing through to do whatever
she wants to do i'm okay missing her at
the initial but if my attack tracking
still catches her when she's in her
dodge i feel like there should be some
form of interrupt or some respect for me
still landing that attack since
sometimes she dodges and i completely
miss but if i dodge an attack from the
boss and they track me and they hit me
during the dodge when i don't have
iframes or at the end of it because they
have better tracking than the player has
we are punished for that and generally
that's okay we just need to dodge
differently the same should apply to
melania this is a one-on-one fight we're
at a similar standing she is a grand
warrior yes but we've killed everything
in the game so asking to have an impact
when we clip her when she's dodging
feels like okay to me that feels like an
okay ass but it isn't there and it makes
the fight just be more frustrating
there's also not allowing certain
attacks or kinds of damage to send her
to phase two which can lead to her
having a health bar with no health it's
literally on zero but because she hasn't
been hit again and because she was sent
to that zero health with the wrong kind
of attack whether that be a visceral or
i'm not sure which specific things cause
it may be just a visceral i don't know
this is an issue it breaks the immersion
it's not like the biggest deal like this
thing by itself but it's something that
just feels it feels emblematic of uh how
there are lots of like small things that
make for a very annoying or frustrating
um aspect of the fight so you just need
to land another hit in this case to send
her to phase two it's a lot of small
things where it's like oh well you need
to do that and you need to also do that
and oh yeah you have to do that oh you
do i know you don't get to do that there
are a lot of things that they're part of
the reason why melania is so hard but
it's hard in the wrong way at least
that's the best way i would say it
without getting into a longer deep dive
on melania and unless it's been patched
how even according to the rules of the
game there are things she breaks which
are it's basically just literally unfair
i can't speak on that more so right now
um if i do a critique video i'm sure
i'll speak on that more so how she
doesn't respect the um mechanics that
the game lays out but i don't know if
that's still the case or if it's been
patched if anybody knows feel free to
say so in the comments and there was a
video series by another creator that i
will link to in the description if i can
find it which highlighted how she kind
of breaks the mechanical rules of the
game overall i just don't have that much
fun fighting against melania because
there are good aspects to her i like her
more than the elden beast
i'm going to put her in c here
and with that my distribution of bosses
is pretty pretty oddly oddly good they
would just be better if i put there's
one right here then it would be a
perfect uh distribu normal distribution
but that is my there's my ranking that
is my tier list of the remembrances of
eldon ring nothing about this is too set
in stone or concrete i'm sure these
change over time and my critique and my
discussion of these bosses because this
is so free-flowing because i'm not
codifying my thoughts as rigidly don't
take this as like horribly strong gospel
but it's just currently where i'm at
with the bosses and when i develop into
a critique of the game i will spend more
time specifically talking about um
intricacies and defending my points of
view more so but i didn't feel the need
completely to do so right now because
i'm not judging them solely based on
favoriteness though my top two bosses
are two of my favorite bosses in terms
of favoriteness granola might be a
little lower margaret morgat might be
ester and if i was just going off of
favoriteness or purely enjoyability but
i tried to have a mix of enjoyability
and just what i think of the quality of
the bosses i think malekith and i think
melania aren't that good at bosses they
have better aspects than the fire giant
similar to how radon has better aspects
than some of the other b tiers but they
also have greater failings which kind of
averages out so to say so this is where
i'm at i think i'm happy to end the
video with these rankings moog maybe i
could stretch to be
morgot i don't know if i would stretch
him to s i don't know if there are any
others i would put in s um i did enjoy
the dragons
maybe if i had a really good experience
run and flow state in one of the bosses
it would be in like an str experience
but so many of the bosses have things
that i feel like get in the way of me
entering a flow state or me entering a
nice dance with the boss just in ways
that i'm not super happy with like i
think the abyss watchers is a good
example of a boss that doesn't have
these issues there are multiple enemies
and it just does it in a really good way
where like the multiple enemies you
eventually get an abyss watcher that
helps fight with you to fight against
the multiple of this watcher enemies and
just the flow of the kit just feels
really good to me even though that's a
boss that took me like 35 tries my first
time playing through dark souls 3. like
that would be a boss i'd probably put a
zest here but i think that'll do it feel
free to do your own tier list and share
with me your thoughts on mine on the
rankings the pros and cons of the bosses
whether or not you think this is a i
would say fair and balanced list but
obviously taste is going to be a large
part of even trying to be objective even
trying to rank the bosses according to
best design um that's going to be a lot
of taste
so this is probably going to be a long
video because the recording is at an
hour and 10 minutes it's not going to be
that long but if you've watched this
whole thing i appreciate you watching
the video i hope you enjoyed it make
sure to subscribe to the channel if you
want to see more content probably not a
lot of more stuff like this but i will
be doing some critique some analysis and
of course i will be doing much more or
because um yeah there's a lot of lore to
discuss and that's what a lot of my
channel is currently so feel free to
subscribe to the channel let me know in
the comments your thoughts on this feel
free to support me on patreon thank you
very much to my patrons um i probably
will put this up before in the video so
i will be late in acknowledging the
patron aspect on the screen but thank
you to my patrons and if you want to
support the channel if you want to help
me just dedicate more time and effort to
these videos becoming a patron on
patreon is the best way to do that so
that does it for the video thank you for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one bye
you